[Music]
i can tell you and this morning in our
series school matters we're looking at
how our friends at sesame street are
helping kids handle the stress of going
back to school
sesame workshop teamed up with the
meditation app headspace to create a
series of monster meditation videos and
books also a new podcast called
good night world they teach meditation
and mindfulness tricks to help little
ones relax and fall asleep and we can
all root for that in this monster
meditation clip grover struggles to do
many things at once too many things you
might say and so andy from headspace
teaches grover to slow down
find a special rhythm and focus on one
task at a time
when you have so much to do breathe in
breathe out
count one two then two
now i shall have breakfast
nice job grover you're really moving
through all the things you wanted to do
ah i am
and i'm pleased to say that grover joins
us now rover good morning
we also have rosemary trulia she's the
senior vice president of curriculum and
content at sesame workshop good morning
to both of you grover when i heard a
furry celebrity was going to be here
this morning i was very excited and i'm
even more excited to see that it's you
oh oh yes it is me
live and in the fur
can we watch some more cartoons well
that cartoon was a good one because it
was teaching kids how to relax and you
learned one of the first big lessons in
that monster meditation how's it been
going well i'd love to meditate yeah
yeah mindfulness exercises they help me
to slow down and feel calmer
yeah what are some of the things you get
nervous about grover
me get nervous you mean like a uh being
in front of uh millions of people on
live television and stuff like that
stuff like that yeah stuff like that i
get really nervous oh my goodness i get
nervous but but this is okay it is okay
yeah because uh you know there are all
sorts of things you can do like uh you
can take deep belly breaths
right how does that work how does that
work grover well you know you breathe in
through your nose and go
and then you let the doll out
and how does that make you feel better i
agree with you how does it make you feel
better well yeah yeah well it calms me
down mm-hmm you know it does not make
all those millions of people go away but
rosemary so many kids are experiencing
heightened anxiety now because of
everything we've been through and going
back to school talk about that a little
bit
well children and and we all have big
feelings and children have a range of
feelings like you could be nervous you
could be worried but you could also be
excited and sometimes you get frustrated
and disappointed
but with children they have these
feelings but they don't have the words
they don't know what how to describe
what what they're feeling so the first
part is to provide the word and say are
you feeling nervous give it a a label
and then to validate how they're feeling
and don't say oh you're going to be fine
that doesn't help children so once they
have the label once they feel that their
emotion is validated then they need
these strategies these tools we all need
these tools and we need a whole tool box
of strategies i love that your voice
and that's that's one of the skills
right to listen to it that's why i have
a soothing story that's how i felt
listening to andy and headspace and the
collaboration because i find his voice
so soothing too but you said that it's
important for adults to help children
identify what we all call what we all
have big feelings you said that's right
and and big feelings are okay to have
yeah right you don't want to suppress
them right you want children to
understand that i'm having a big feeling
and i'm going to call it frustration or
disappointment or worry or nervousness
and then help them figure out well how
can we make this big feeling feel better
like it's not a light switch it doesn't
go off in a second but what can i do to
calm that big feeling down so that we
could talk about what's going on and
then more importantly how we're going to
move on to the next activity
you record can you record your voice so
i can listen to it later okay okay group
we could work something out rover you
you learned you learned a breathing
exercise right to help you fall asleep
can you share it with us well sure well
you know they're they they belly breaths
but i also um you know i like to wind
down
uh by imagining a cute little soap
bubble
yeah that is what i do that works very
well yeah yeah let's let's all watch a
cute little soap bubble let's all
imagine it floating up
up
into the air
that works not very exciting
surprisingly effective hey
we're all calm now right yes yes yes
rover what about reading a lot of kids
like books some of them may even like
the monster meditation book do you have
a favorite book at bedtime
well my mommy i i like for my mommy to
read to me at night the bedtime story
because her voice is also very soothing
it is very soothing but uh
nobody here knows the end of the three
little pigs do you because i i never
can't get to the end of that one i
always fall asleep before we get to the
end speaking of parents
rosemary
how can parents help in this situation
well first of all children are watching
us yeah so it's always they're always
watching they're watching even when you
don't think they're watching absolutely
and so it's really important for all of
us because these meditation skills are
not just for children they're for all of
us to learn and to have in our toolbox
because we're going to have reactions
and we're going to have
big big feelings and emotions so
the whole idea is to know what these
practices are belly breathing imagining
uh counting to four
um and and to use them yourself to
practice these skills and to use them
yourself so that when we have a big
feeling your child is seeing how we're
handling it managing it and then to help
them practice
right because there's no such thing as
one tool is going to be the magic bullet
and we want them to have a range of
couples we used to have to count to ten
now you're saying counting counts
i like following the soap bubble grover
thank you for that tip i feel much
better are you feeling grover and thank
you for being here rosemarie thank you
as well it's been a pleasure good night
world from sesame workshop and headspace
is available wherever you get your
podcast